pourquoi la peinture même dans les
paysages un sens politique
ça c'est la grosse question ça c'est un
sujet qui a été abondamment traitée par
un historien d'art qui s'appelle martin
veyron que en ce qui concerne le 19e
siècle
c'est souvent un moyen de façonner
l'image d'un pays à travers son paysage
et donc il ya souvent un rapport à la
fondation des états nations au 19e
siècle à travers le paysage de la nation
en ce qui concerne à la peinture danoise
puisque c'est notre sujet on a donc des
artistes qui au début de la période par
beaucoup en italie qui peignent beaucoup
les paysages italiens et petit à petit
qu'ils vont être exhorté par eugène qui
est l'historien de l'art de l'époque le
critique d'art de l'époque a plutôt
arpenté le danemark le pays et à aller
vers les pays scandinaves pour peindre à
la fois le peuple suédois ou alors les
grands paysages de norvège les fjords
etc
c'est un acte politique dans la mesure
où ça permet de montrer l'image de la
nation danoise est donc représenté le
pays représentés
à quoi ressemble le danemark avec ses
forêts de hêtres ou avec la lande du
jute landes avec ses fjords avec ses
littoraux c'est une manière de
s'approprier le pays et surtout de faire
en sorte que les citoyens danois le
peuple danois se l'approprient on a
également des tableaux qui sont a priori
très neutre comme la vue du lac sorte
d'âme par coop que on voit dans les skis
ce préparatoire au tableau à un paysage
très neutre et dans la version finale
kopke ajoute le drapeau danois au bout
d'une amp pour vraiment signifier que le
paysage c'est le paysage danois donc il
ya vraiment un sens politique au sens de
vraiment faire reconnaître ce qu'est le
pays pour tout le monde c'est à dire
pour les citoyens mais aussi à
l'extérieur du dan
[Musique]